S
TO SEND ABOUT 1000 MORE WEAPONS
TO RUSSIA, INCLUDING ADVANCED
GUIDED MISSILES FOR MOSCOW'S
WAR IN UKRAINE.
TORONTO'S ALREADY SURPRISED NEW
DRUGS.
THIS COMES A SHORT TIME AFTER
THE MAYOR OF KYIV ANNOUNCED FOR
POWER IS ON IN THE CAPITAL.
IT BEARS ARE STORED 24 HOURS
AFTER RUSSIAN MISSILES TARGETED
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE IN KYIV
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT, VOLODYMYR
ZELENSKYY, SAYS MOST OF THE
MISSILES MOSCOW FIRED WERE
BROUGHT DOWN BY AIR DEFENSES
AND THE REPAIR WORK GOES ON.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
[INTERPRETER]
AS OF NOW, RESTORATION WORKS
ARE STILL ONGOING, WHERE THERE
WERE HITS BY RUSSIAN MISSILES
TODAY.
WE ARE DOING EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO RESTORE THE ENERGY
AND WATER SUPPLY, AND WE WILL
RESTORE IT.
[END OF TRANSLATION]
>> CNN'S CLARISSA WARD IS IN
SEPARATE FOR US TODAY.
CLARISSA, WHAT WILL THESE EXTRA
WEAPONS HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE
GROUND WHERE YOU ARE, DO YOU
THINK?
>> MAX, WE DON'T REALLY KNOW
YET WHEN THESE WEAPONS WOULD
ACTUALLY ARRIVE IN RUSSIA.
SO, WHEN THEY WOULD START BEING
USED.
BUT OBVIOUSLY, THERE IS GOING
TO BE A LARGE AMOUNT OF CONCERN
ABOUT THIS, PARTICULARLY WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT PRECISION
GUIDED MISSILES AND DRONES,
WHICH HAD SUCH A DEVASTATING
EFFECT ON THE BATTLEFIELD,
PARTICULARLY IN THE LAST MONTH.
I AM STANDING HERE RIGHT BEHIND
ME, YOU CAN PROBABLY SEE THIS
IS WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE WHEN A
LARGE MISSILE SLAMS INTO A
RESIDENTIAL AREA.
THIS ACTUALLY HAPPENS A FEW
WEEKS AGO, BUT YOU CAN GET A
PICTURE ON THE LEVEL OF
WEAPONRY WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
WITH AND DEALING WITH HERE.
THIS IS A NORMAL APARTMENT
BUILDING.
THREE PEOPLE WERE KILLED.
SEVEN PEOPLE WERE INJURED.
AND JUST YESTERDAY, YOU
MENTIONED IN YOUR INTRODUCTION.
MORE THAN 50 MISSILES FIRED AT
UKRAINE.
UKRAINIAN AIR FORCE SAYING THEY
WERE ABLE TO INTERCEPT MORE
THAN 40 OF THEM, WHICH IS A
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS RATE, BUT AS
YOU, KNOW MAX, EVEN JUST A FEW
THAT MANAGED TO GET THROUGH, IF
THEY HIT THOSE TARGETS, AND THE
TARGET NOW IS VERY MUCH
CIVILIAN INFRASTRUCTURE, THEN,
THEY STILL CAN HAVE A
DEVASTATING IMPACT.
, SO.
YES THERE WILL BE A GREAT DEAL
OF CONCERN ABOUT MORE WEAPONRY
BEING PUMPED INTO RUSSIA AT
THIS CRUCIAL POINT IN THE WAR,
MAX.
>> YOU'RE ABOUT TO GET INTO
THIS VERY COLD PERIOD, ALREADY
TWO, IN UKRAINE?
HOW CONCERNED ARE PEOPLE ABOUT
THESE ATTACKS ON THE HEATING
SYSTEM, FOR EXAMPLE?
>> LISTEN, MAX.
YOU'VE HEARD FROM PRESIDENT
VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY.
HE HAS TOLD THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE, IN VARIOUS BARE TERMS,
THIS IS GOING TO BE THE HARDEST
WINTER EVER.
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS HAVE ALSO
SAID IF YOU ARE LIVING OUTSIDE
THE COUNTRY, OR YOU'VE GONE
OUTSIDE THE COUNTRY FOR A WHILE,
DON'T COME BACK HOME.
THE GRID, AS IT STANDS, CANNOT
COPE WITH MORE PEOPLE LIVING
HERE.
THEY ARE BEING ASKED TO --
SHOPS CAN'T HAVE LIGHTS ON.
RESTAURANTS, EVERYONE HAS TO
MINIMIZE THE AMOUNT OF
ELECTRICITY THEY USE.
AND STILL, EVERY TIME YOU HAVE
THESE ATTACKS, YOU ARE HAVING
ROLLING BLACKOUTS.
YOU HAVE SITUATIONS LIKE
YESTERDAY IN KYIV, WHERE 40% OF
THE CITY WERE WITHOUT WATER,
WERE YOU WERE SUDDENLY SEEING
LINES OF PEOPLE COLLECTING
WATER TO STOCK UP IN
PREPARATION FOR MORE OF THESE
ATTACKS ON CIVILIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE, BECAUSE THE
FEELING HERE ON THE GROUND IS
THIS PROBABLY ISN'T GOING TO GO
AWAY, AND THAT'S WHY YOU'RE
SEEING UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS
CALLING FOR MORE AIR DEFENSE
AND ALSO CALLING ON MORE
SUPPORT AND MATERIALS FOR
TRYING TO REBUILD THE GRID.
THEY ARE TRYING TO KEEP UP.
IT